olá
quem já ajudou alguém qualquer tamanho
de coisa na vida
levanta a mão legal
que bom que todo mundo quem é que já foi
ajudado por alguém que nunca conheceu
que bom também bom eu ivan e vou falar
um pouco sobre a pensar se esquece a
palavra não importa muito a tecnicidade
da coisa que eu quero passar para vocês
um pouco da minha história um pouco de
como eu cheguei nessa coisa que até
então eu não sabia
chamava essa palavra é eu nasci em 1994
e desde quando eu me lembro e me entendo
por gente eu sempre gostei muito de
descobrir as coisas e aprender coisas de
correr atrás de criar coisas também
eu vi essa frase eu gostei bastante dela
que ela mostra um pouco como a gente se
comporta a gente esquece muito fácil as
coisas que a gente vê as coisas que a
gente ouve mas a gente dificilmente
esquece como a gente se sentiu em algum
momento e é um pouco disse que eu quero
mostrar hoje
bom eu sempre gostei me divertir
eu era uma pessoa que gostava de cinema
gostava de acampar gostava de mexer no
photoshop
e esse é o tipo de coisa que eu fazia
porque eu não era bom futebol e até hoje
não sou bom esse tipo de coisa me
motivava porque como era muito ruim e
até hoje eu sou ruim esportes eu corri
atrás de coisas um pouco mais diferentes
e uma coisa que eu sempre gostei desde o
meu 67 anos que era uma coisa tava
começando era robótica até então
robótica era uma coisa que eu só ouvia
falar eu nunca tive na escola e eu
sempre quis participar de competição de
robótica
só que na minhas escolas que eu estudei
isso em algumas eu nunca tive essa
oportunidade e por sorte essa foi uma
barreira que eu consegui vencer promete
é por causa dos meus amigos que a gente
se juntou e montou uma equipe chama de
garagem garagem não é
a gente fica na garagem mas a gente se
reunia na casa de amigos ea gente
competir
essa é a nossa equipe não vou falar quem
sou eu li tudo bem e em 2006 quando
tinha 10 anos e anos foi quando eu
aprendi a minha primeira linguagem de
programação e essa foi a parte que eu
mais gostei porque eu sempre quis
aprender programa mas eu nunca sabia
como começar
mas a partir daí foi quando comecei a
descobrir várias e várias coisas e na
nossa equipe
a gente sempre trazia muitas coisas de
forma a gente chamava hemeroteca ea
gente chegou a competir em campeonatos
regionais e nacionais ea gente conseguiu
ir para o mundial em atlanta
foi um evento muito legal muito legal
porque tinham equipes do mundo inteiro e
muito mais ainda porque as equipes do
mundo inteiro não era uma equipe que
estava ali para competir somente elas
estavam ali compartilhando conhecimento
seria no estande deles você vai estar lá
como vocês fizeram isso qual foi o
projeto de pesquisa de vocês e todos
eles estão muito abertos
não era uma coisa competitiva era uma
coisa cooperativa que as pessoas não
estavam ali querendo ser melhores que as
outras e sim querendo fazer o seu melhor
ah eu me interessei muito programação e
eu comecei a pesquisar bastante a
aprender como fazer site como fazer
aquilo como fazer aquilo e várias dessas
coisas eu fui aprendendo em paralelo né
e essa linha da direita é uma linha do
tempo das coisas que eu ia pegando da
internet
coisas que eu ia aprendendo coisas que
eu ia absorvendo a gente conseguiu
novamente para um outro campeonato
mundial na turquia com outro tipo de
competição que é o robô campo ea gente
foi com robô totalmente franquista em
que ele o robô que parece um fusca todo
capenga caindo todas as peças e quando
chegou lá a gente viu aonde a gente
queria chegar que era ter um robô
projetado rio bonito como se fosse uma
ferrari
ele falou a gente quer chegar ali mas
para chegar ali com que a gente sabe a
gente não tem como fazer isso
foi por isso que a gente aprendeu mais
outras milhares de coisas e durante esse
processo
a gente aprendeu bastante então pensa
aquela lado direito a gente está sempre
puxando conhecimento seja quando você
entra na internet quando você ler um
livro você está aprendendo está
aprendendo aprendendo aprendendo
bom a gente foi pra holanda e na verdade
méxico e depois holanda e na holanda a
gente foi com um robô totalmente
diferente do que todas as pessoas já
tinham feito a gente cria o código é um
conceito bem simples de um robô para
aquele tipo de competição utilizavam seu
android e aqui por exemplo uma foto e
uma renderização 3d mas foi legal aqui a
gente criou tanta coisa ali e quando eu
falo tanto é mais ou menos 10 a 3 mil
linhas de código que a gente escreveu em
34 meses
então você pensa em escrever um livro só
que aquele livro está com quem tá comigo
ia morrer comigo com quem estava na
minha equipe
quando a gente voltou nesse campeonato a
gente pensou puts tok informação isso a
informação não é só dado já é uma
informação muito bem bolada já dedicou
muito tempo aqui a gente criou tantas
coisas tanto na parte de software
eletrônica mecânica adquirir um modelo e
esse modelo ou a gente usa pra gente
ficar melhor e competir ou a gente
compartilha para compartilhar não é tão
simples né não é só você pegar um bronze
pai colocar na internet
o upload então a gente resolveu
simplificar e explicar esse processo
como era feito cada coisa ea gente
dividiu isso em várias pequenas partes
como este é uma grande coisa a gente
dividiu isso é bom
a pergunta que a gente fez foi
justamente porque não compartilhar né
porque não fazer isso hoje sente bem por
que não nas coisas a gente pode acabar
fazendo qualquer coisa mas a gente fez
essa pergunta e não tinha nenhum porque
não
e foi aí que a gente dividiu isso e
compartilhou isso lá no meu clube tem
várias bibliotecas para a ruína nesse
caso tem vários projetos open source de
inteligência artificial até várias
coisinhas divertidas e que eu já
dediquei
muito tempo pra isso nossa equipe já
dedicou muito tempo pra isso e essas
coisas são coisas que estão públicas
agora qualquer um pode pegar pode pegar
isso e fazer alguma coisa em cima quando
essa linha veio para a direita
foi aí que a gente fez open source foi
que ficou pensar se foi uma coisa que
você dedicou um tempo que você dedicou
seu coração soso suas viradas de noite
ou sábado ou domingo e aí você falou
putz porque não compartilhar e aí você
compartilha é uma coisa simples não é
falando fuchs mas botou na internet é
realmente o que é isso
essa software né eu posso fazer isso com
a música eu posso fazer isso com que
pode fazer com que quiser a gente pode
fazer
de qualquer forma porque o pensar se não
é uma coisa ele é mais ou menos uma
cultura é uma cultura de que você faz
legal
aí faço isso então beleza ajuda a gente
aqui ou eu vou ajudar vocês porque eu
quero que isso melhore é tanto as duas
vias
então definir a cultura que inclui todo
mundo pra resolver um problema e ele
funciona em qualquer lugar e em qualquer
lugar que é muito legal que a partir do
momento que eu divulguei quilo na
internet
tem gente da coreia veio gente da europa
veio gente de estados unidos de vários
lugares e foram lá no código falam olha
isso aqui pode ficar melhor assim
se você tivesse feito isso você poderia
ter melhorado olha vão alterar o nome de
sua equipe que você errou no inglês já
aconteceu
é eu aprendi a falar algumas palavras e
esse tipo de coisa é uma troca de
informação e que as pessoas não estão
ali porque elas estão recebendo elas
estão ali porque elas querem realmente
utilizar o que você fez ou que várias
pessoas fizeram e poupar tempo
simplesmente porque elas não querem
eu não quero refazer a roda não quero
reinventar a roda aquele negócio de anão
reinventa a roda é justamente por isso
que já tem muita coisa pronta as pessoas
já dedicaram neurônios para pensar nisso
para resolver problemas e o que a gente
quer é resolver problemas ainda maiores
e quando você fala pô
mas eu pensava em uma coisa que nem pra
que eu vou fazer saber só pessoas
a google por exemplo no ano passado no
final soltou o que chama de flow flow é
uma indígena é um ponto fosse uma
biblioteca que serve pra inteligência
artificial para você treinar uma
inteligência artificial
isso foi uma coisa que eles divulgaram
que eles usam internamente para treinar
até mesmo a surgir games deles né a
busca treinar como aprender e imagens
para você pode falar o que o google
fight for ozu e na cara e ele acha suas
fotos no carro entender reconhecimento
de voz e várias outras coisas também
genérico eles divulgaram isso e você
pode entrar lá dá um convite você pode
ajudar esse projeto e essas outras
coisas elas são muito populares hoje
muito provavelmente porque elas são o
pensar foram ao pensar nisso desde o
início
aqui a gente pode ver impressora 3d quem
tem uma impressora 3d em casa
ok algumas pessoas três pessoas que
legal
eu tenho uma impressora 3d em casa e uma
impressora que foi o pensar se desde o
início é uma impressora 3d que as
pessoas só puderam fazer porque o
projeto estava na internet porque já
tinha uma receita de um bolo lá pra você
fazer um drone por exemplo como que não
seria criar um drone sem ter o programa
dele sem saber onde comprar o motor ohc
motor usar ou como você ia fazer
estrutura sabe arduino que é uma
plataforma open source e ainda assim a
empresa ganha dinheiro né
e até mesmo um andróide quem tem android
aqui aí várias pessoas levantavam esse
de android é uma plataforma totalmente
aberta e muito por isso tem várias e
várias inovações que outras plataformas
não tem porque é o cara que vê lá e dá o
bug fala eu vim aqui porque
aconteceu isso eu já fiz isso uma vez aí
eu entrei no código do android fiaa é
por causa disso beleza eu podia ter
feito que alterado e mandaram uma
alteração e o android é se melhorar e
assim que acontece tanto na parte
segurança interface e tudo isso é uma
coisa coletiva e funciona em qualquer
lugar não preciso estar nos estados
unidos pra programar o android posso
programar aqui programa de marketing na
internet
bom música também é uma coisa pensões
pode ser open source
eu gosto de brincar no piano e às vezes
eu pego a música e coloco no soundcloud
como licença gratuita e uma das coisas
que eu mais gosto é impressão 3d criar
robôs mexer com eletrônica e programação
e esse é um site que chama timbers acho
que o nome já diz bem que ele é
essa é uma das coisas que há uns três ou
quatro anos atrás eu desenhei no
computador e coloquei ó
neste universo que é um espaço pra você
botar peças em 3d
então aos poucos você esteja em casa
precisa de um saleiro entra lá a visita
saleiro a e clicar em imprimir e você
tem o saleiro eu tenho que ler em casa
mas o desenho isso aqui levou nem vai
uma hora uma hora e pouquinho eu vi isso
na rua um negócio bem feio falei pô
disse que uma idéia eu cheguei lá eu
desenhei isso aqui é um seguro de sacola
é pra ir pra sequência cola aqui na
época que eu fiz eu dei pra minha mãe
que morava em vitória e eu não fazia
compras ainda mas eu vim pra cá para são
paulo comecei a morar sozinho e imprimir
duas eo legal é que essa coisa tem mais
ou menos 20 mil a 30 mil downloads hoje
tem pessoas que usam isso no mundo
inteiro e eu não ganhei um centavo por
isso
mas com certeza se eu tivesse colocado
um preço 10 pessoas teriam isso minha
família
bom esse segurado está cola é uma coisa
muito simples mas que explica um pouco
do que eu posso te ajudar mas sem saber
quem você é
eu posso ajudar de uma forma bem geral
global
esse cara por exemplo deu pra noiva dele
e eles publicam bom o que eu ganho com
isso tem forma de ganhar dinheiro tem
tem várias formas mas o que eu mais
gosto de ganhar com isso é justamente as
pessoas usando algo que você fez e
melhorando algo que você fez e esse algo
que você fez virar algo que pessoas
fizeram isso vira uma coisa em grupo não
vira mais uma pessoa somente vira um
projeto coletivo um cara por exemplo uma
biblioteca minha e colocou no youtube
eu não entendo o que está escrito mas
enfim ainda bem que ele colocou ainda
trad uma outra empresa pegou e até
caminha e criou um sistema pra é um com
doyle automático de câmeras e põe a
posição inicial final ele faz meio que
um time lapse e assim usam bibliotecas
coisas que ele poderia ter refeito mas
ele não fez ele pegou uma coisa me
colocou lá evans e do dono da biblioteca
tal e tem pessoas no youtube também que
vão falar putz
é fantástico isso daí gostei pra caramba
e me incentivou a prender inteligência
artificial sabe então são formas de você
ganhar né
indiretamente e como eu faço isso eu
falei é só pegar a cepa e colocar na
internet você baixariam zip da internet
sem saber o que é bom
pensem que precisa ter a documentação
que a parte mais chata de todas
você pensa que se você escrever dez
linhas de código que você precisa
escrever cinco a dez linhas de
documentação para a pessoa entender o
que você está fazendo ali se ela não
entende ela não vai usar o que você está
fazendo e o que você está fazendo vai
servir somente pra você
essa foi uma documentação uma das
documentações que eu escrevi e a parte
mais chata mesmo tentei fazer mas tem
que fazer e pensa na documentação como
se fosse vai
da de alguma coisa que você monta na tok
stok
aliás não péssimo exemplo é muito
difícil é um manual de lego
ok então você precisa dizer as peças e
deixar simples para as pessoas
entenderem que não pode fazer isso daí
tem que ter um padrão manter um padrão
seja lá qual ele for você tem que
escrever vai ser assim assim e assim né
quem nunca fez isso na vida existem
várias ferramentas hoje aqui tem três e
derrame que é um lugar na internet como
se fosse uma rede social para você
colocar códigos na internet muitas vezes
você chega aí indiretamente 2 35 e para
criar circuitos online têm deveres como
eu falei e aqui é um site para você
escolher licença que é uma das partes
chatas também eu não sabia o que eu
precisava em uma licença né
e aí eu achei esse site por acaso ele é
o pensar também olha que redundância
recursividade mas ele explica assim você
quer isso isso isso aí você falar eu
quero isso então beleza tem várias
formas de você deixar sua coisa pública
é bom quando chega num momento em que
pude ver várias coisas que você fez
várias pessoas estão utilizando pode não
estar ganhando nada mas foi uma opção
minha
será que eu fiz certo sabe deixar o pior
será se eu devia ter fechado isso que
deveria ter feito né
neste mapa que está atrás por exemplo
não é de calor tá é um mapa de locais
onde as pessoas é contribuíram para uma
biblioteca a minha verdade foi um
projeto de inteligência artificial que
eu fiz com joão
a gente fez o dinossauro da google
aprender a jogar aquele jogo sozinho
então ele fica lá tentando tentando
tentando e com uma rede neural e aprendi
a jogar a gente fez um vídeo colocado no
youtube tem celular 40 mil visualizações
e várias downloads vários likes então é
uma coisa que várias pessoas estão
contribuindo também e você pensa até
onde eu fiz certo né
até mesmo nas coisas simples isso aqui
por exemplo foi uma foto que eu recebi
é de uma fábio lago de um laboratório de
criação na áfrica do sul
e você percebe as coisas de uma maneira
um pouco indireta e aí que você gosta
bastante vocês incentivo e motiva mais
fazer esse vírus tem abbey road ali e aí
pra finalizar eu digo não façam isso
porque vocês querem ajudar as pessoas
eu faço isso não só porque eu quero
ajudar mas eu vejo isso como uma forma
de agradecer agradecer pelo que eu
aprendi porque aprendi isso de uma
maneira gratuita é aprendiz uma maneira
simples
então eu falo agradeço